Victor Davis Hansen is a senior fellow
at the Hoover institution joins us
tonight to assess Professor thanks for
coming on wouldn't it be nice to see
somebody pay some price for ineptitude
and indifference
yeah it would he's he's jumped the
proverbial shark though he's the epitome
of the empty resume class I mean his
only qualifications for the job were his
identity politics credentials and the
fact he went to Harvard and Oxford and
the media and the bike also Elite Gaga
over him but otherwise Tucker he had the
on Midas Touch everything he's touched
whether it was the port crowding at our
major ports or the train robbing of
trains going into the ports or these
recent four accidents where airliners
almost crashed or the Southwest
implosion or the whole meltdown during
the holiday season of our Airline system
or these rail car everything he either
ignores or he offers these platitudes
and how ironic that right on the Eve or
right in the midst I should say of this
tragedy in East Palestine of this white
working class tiny Community with the
income average income about forty five
thousand dollars he was lecturing the
Nay nation that white hard hats don't
look like the community they are working
in and that's not true it's it's not
only that is he pandering but he's often
interaccurate and ignorant here in
California most of the construction
workers you see on the the elite Coast
are Hispanic and most of the residents
are white upper class people that's just
the way America works but he always
tries to in lieu of actually doing
something he always tries to have a
rhetorical or an abstract Victory and I
think people finally just feel you know
they're tired of them and he's afraid
he's also he talks very bold and like
he's bold and he's Dynamic but he's very
cowardly because he's afraid to go in
and confront these people and tell them
why that FEMA wasted two weeks before
they address their concerns and why he
hasn't been there and I we know the
reason is that he doesn't want to sit
there and talk to people when they ask
him questions he can't answer and so
he's just sort of one brought this
entire cabinet is that this cabinet was
either predicated on being an identity
politics first in their field so to
speak or they were candidates that
pulled out and gave the nomination to
Joe Biden but otherwise none of them had
any demonstrable experience or expertise
in the field that they were supposed to
serve us the people that's right it's
just a little bit funny they've been
lecturing us now for two years about
something called environmental racism
and then there's an actual environmental
disaster in the midst of a community of
people who didn't vote for them and they
ignore it that actually does look like
environmental racism to me
it is and the reason is is that East
Palestine is right on the border of
Pennsylvania and it's in Klinger it's
the very area that in 2008 uh Barack
Obama blasted as they cling to their
religion and then we know how Joe Biden
has called Trump supporters Chumps and
drags and we know the irredeemables and
deplorable vocabulary of uh Hillary
Clinton so they have a long record of
disparagement of the white working class
I don't know why they think they can
just get away with it so easily without
some kind of reaction but they are it is
racist and if this was in Malibu or this
was in Martha's Vineyard or even in
Compton or South Central there would be
an immediate U.S government response by
this Administration right among the rich
or the fashionable poor but these people
fall through the cracks right every
single time Vic Davis Hanson joining us
tonight thank you so much
thank thank you